welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with pomp and
circumstance and a high profile visit in
hong kong as the city observes a 25-year
anniversary of independence from british
rule chinese president xi jinping made
his first trip off the mainland since
the start of the pandemic to help
celebrate the anniversary and he wasn't
shy about the prospects for china to
seize control over even more territory
elizabeth palmer reports
china's president xi jinping arrived in
hong kong by train on a victory tour to
celebrate the 25th anniversary of china
taking hong kong back
[Music]
in 1997 britain's flag came down over
the territory for the last time
marking the end of more than 150 years
of british rule
and for a while life carried on under
china's so-called one country two
systems policy in other words beijing
promised not to interfere
but slowly that changed and in 2019
violent protests erupted over a law that
would have sent people arrested in hong
kong to china for trial
in the end the demonstrators lost and
china cemented its hold
on in his keynote speech on friday xi
jinping doubled down
we must implement the principle of
patriots administering hong kong he said
outside there was heavy security and
plenty of nationalist hoopla
which to people 500 miles away on the
island of taiwan looked like a threat
in hong kong freedom and democracy have
vanished said its premier sued sen
taiwan must hold fast to its sovereignty
but it's not going to be easy china
views taiwan as its own and xi jinping
has made it clear he wants to bring it
just like hong kong under beijing's firm
control
for cbs saturday morning elizabeth
palmer tokyo